I just got a 3d printer probably
unrelated I've never used a 3d printer
before this will probably go well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I've printed some stuff so my
very first prints like a harp no it's
actually a raft I'm pretty sure to the
file so once I got the printer all set
up I did the bed leveling and all that
and kind of figure out how to use the
computer thing the next thing is of
course print something so in order to
print something you go from like the 3d
model to like an STL file and then you
load that STL file into a slicing
program or a slicer anyway I've been
using cura and then you output that to
the g-code and then you load the g-code
on to your 3d print and print now I had
no idea how to do the slicing so I was
just like okay I'll just use whatever's
on the printer and they they happen to
have a dog g-code so that started to
print this and I decided that's gonna be
way too big it's probably gonna take
like five six seven plus hours so it's
like nevermind so I stopped the print
but still my first print now then I went
and found how to use a slicer super
simple you just drag and drop the STL
you pick some various settings and then
you output the g-code so this is the
second thing I printed I mean just
really beautiful I guess the problem
here like the printer just kind of
nothing stuck and so that's the issue
what ended up happening is it just never
stuck to the bed now everybody uses
different methods for getting things to
adhere to the bed in this case this
printer has a heated bed so a heated bed
plus printing on glass shouldn't work
now not everybody does that some people
are still gonna have a heated bed glass
and use something like a glue stick or
put tape down but from what I was
finding online it looked like no you
should be fine on glass so I wanted to
continue plus I mean I did get this
right so this did adhere so it's just
trying to figure out
like what what is wrong and this is what
I believe to be a raft so then I went
back to the slicer added a raft and then
I got finally this so I was just trying
to find something really small to test
the printer test things like this where
it's like you know because I wanted to
be able to watch the entire print
because you're trying to figure out what
settings to pick so your printer doesn't
just end up in a huge mess and so
especially when you're starting out you
probably want to be able to watch the
print though almost the entire time if
not the entire time because there's all
kinds of stuff like as you get into the
print like at what point should you be
setting up supports and all this kind of
stuff so anyways print number three
great success okay so here's a sped up
version of me designing this cup in
fusion 360 unfortunately fusion 360 you
can't see like the options and stuff
that I'm picking I don't know the
software is kind of funky it just
doesn't like to be recorded but for
whatever reason but anyways it was
pretty impressive to me how quickly I
could actually like model and make a cup
because basically I just wrote down on
paper kind of the dimensions that I
wanted and then I just converted that
right into fusion 360s so super
impressed with fusion 360 is software is
concerned it's a pretty there's so much
to learn but it's pretty intuitive of a
program so I definitely have a lot to
learn there was a tutorial I went
through to learn at least the basics and
then I went to go make this cup and I
was like dude I don't I mean like how do
I make the cup it's like oh my gosh I
got so much to learn but slowly but
surely figuring out how to do various
things and once again the community is
there and super super helpful so yeah
eventually I did get a cup sent that bad
boy to the printer and got that done
alright and we have a cup that we
created so take off the bottom raft bit
then this was the support and hopefully
I can pop out the support here without
destroying the other parts it's hard
because the piece that's supported is
all like pretty small so I'm trying to
about this other piece but it's pretty
well-connected I'm just trying not to
break the other plastic I mean at least
with the boat everything was actually
way more sturdy than I thought yeah
there we go look cool nice so now I have
a nice small cup not sure I would
recommend drinking out of it I was
thinking of using it for a coffee scoop
cool that's pretty cool to go from
something you designed to actually
printing it alright so first three
prints pretty cool I've learned so much
since I got this printer it's been
really cool there's been like so much
information available online for this
sort of thing I mean I can't imagine
what it was like getting a 3d printer in
the really truly early days now onto the
topic of this Cup so my intention
actually is was to use this as a coffee
scoop so this doesn't really matter but
well after I printed it there's no way
you'll see it on the video but it just
looked like the bottom layer was really
thin like the thickness of the walls of
the cup or actually it's supposed to be
I can't remember if it was 2 or 3
millimeters but there's supposed to be
some thickness there but for some reason
I just noticed that it's really thin and
sure enough if I just put some like
water in here it's really hard to tell
but it's definitely like dripping from
the bottom and so you I mean I did
intend for it to be a cup even though
being a coffee scoop that does not
matter I was kind of curious like what
like what went wrong and to be honest
with you I I don't really have the
answer so if I pull up the the modeling
here this is the actual model in fusion
360 and I mean I see the bottom exists
right like it's definitely there and
then when I push this model to Kira
here's that model and like it's pretty
hard to see you know in there but if you
do if we go to slice and I'll just slice
it the same way I did before and we go
preview and then I change this
to x-ray view I still see that there's
bass there like like it clearly looks
like it should have been there and I'm
just a little confused as to why it's
not so if anybody has any idea on what
is going on there feel free to share or
not sure if any how many of my viewers
have 3d printers but anyway that's kind
of curious I would want to figure that
out but overall pretty excited I've made
a lot more progress with doing 3d
printing and modeling and stuff and I
thought I put in such a short period of
time so that's pretty cool really super
thankful that there's such a huge
community out there I just didn't
realize there's such a huge community
for like every little thing you could
possibly need or every issue you've come
across it's just like programming like
the someone else has already experienced
this so it's pretty cool so moving
forward there's lots of things I
definitely want to do one of the things
I'd like to do is get this thing called
octo print oh I think this is all goofy
because I've got maybe the cat me see if
I minimize it No
yeah that looks terrible let me fix this
I think that should do it
hopefully yeah interesting fusion 360 is
not nice to obs
anyways this thing called octoprint you
put on our Raspberry Pi and you can like
manage first of all you can manage your
3d printer remotely but then also
there's like including the management
you've also got the ability basically
you know send and receive files from it
and then also just monitor it even with
like a video feed so I could put it like
I don't know if I really want to keep
the printer in here especially if I
printed something like ABS I probably
want that in my workshop so because you
just want to inhale that stuff the PLA
is okay I've read questionable studies
about having that in your like in a room
but probably ideally it would go into
the workshop so I would really want to
have something like this so I'm not like
running back and forth doing that but
anyway pretty cool maybe more stuff with
3d printing Nakano got lots of lots of
stuff that I've always wanted to be able
to have a 3d printer for but I just
couldn't couldn't do it cuz I didn't
have a 3d printer so I've got one pretty
cool hope you guys enjoyed let me know
if you want to see more content with 3d
printing otherwise I'll see you later
and finally a shout out to the people
who make stuff like this possible my
channel members so going on there a
ninth month now we've got mr. Jean jeans
Edward William Sam's Edward McCain
Thiago Lima and Rodrigo Silva thank you
guys very much for your support if you
didn't know you can support the channel
by clicking on that let's see if I can
make it yep that beautiful blue join
button right there okay until next time